el cáncer cervical es uno de los tipos
de cáncer con mayores posibilidades de
prevención mediante exámenes regulares y
es altamente curable cuando se descubre
a tiempo puede tomar medidas para evitar
exponerse al vph o virus del papiloma
humano la causa más común de cáncer
cervical limitando el número de personas
con las que mantiene relaciones sexuales
evitando parejas sexuales que participen
en actividades de alto riesgo retrasando
el sexo hasta hacer mayor y utilizando
condones para ayudar a evitar la
propagación del vph y otras enfermedades
de transmisión sexual evite fumar lo que
aumenta el riesgo de cáncer cervical en
las mujeres infectadas con vph vacunarse
con gardasil que evita la infección con
los dos tipos de vph y responsables de
la mayoría de casos de cáncer cervical
su meta se exámenes de papanicolau cada
año que detectan cambios pre
cancerígenas en el cuello uterino que
podrían dar paso al cáncer cervical si
no son tratados a tiempo su meta sea el
examen para detectar el vph que detecta
el vph en el cuello uterino asegúrese de
hablar con su médico
formas para reducir su riesgo de padecer
cáncer cervical